we've got some apples here and we've got
some oranges and what I want to think
about is what is the ratio what is the
ratio of apples of apples to oranges to
oranges and to clarify what we're even
talking about a ratio is giving us the
relationship between quantities of two
different things so there's a couple of
ways that we can specify this we can
literally count the number of apples 1 2
3 4 5 6 so we have 6 apples and we could
say the ratio is going to be 6 - 6 - and
then how many oranges do we have 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 it is 6 to 9 ratio of apples
to oranges is 6 to 9 and you could use
different notation you could also write
it this way 6 - you would still read it
is the ratio is being 6 to 9 but we
don't have to just satisfy us with this
because one way to think about ratios if
we're especially for thinking about
apples to oranges is how many apples do
we have for a certain number of oranges
and when you think about it that way we
can actually reduce these numbers as you
might have already thought about both 6
& 9 are divisible by 3 so just how like
we can reduce fractions we can also
reduce ratios so if you divide 6 and 9
both by 3 6 divided by 3 is 2 6 divided
by 3 is 2 and 9 divided by 3 is 3 so we
could also say that the ratio of apples
to oranges is 2 to 3 or if we want to
use this notation - 2 3 2 2 3 now does
that make sense
well look we divided each of these
groups into three so one way to think
about it so if you divide if you divide
this whole total into 3 groups so one
group one group two groups
two groups and three equal groups we see
that in each of those groups for every
two apples for every two apples we have
three oranges for two apples we have
three oranges for two apples we have
three oranges so once again the ratio of
apples to oranges for every two apples
we have three oranges but we could think
about things the other way around as
well we could also think about what is
the ratio we could also think about what
is the ratio ratio of oranges to apples
oranges to apples and here we would
essentially switch the numbers the ratio
of oranges to apples notice up here we
said apples to oranges which is six to
nine or two to three if we reduce them
and here we're going to say the ratio of
oranges to apples so we've swapped these
two and so we're going to swap the
numbers here we have nine oranges for
every six apples so we could say the
ratio is going to be nine to six the
ratio is 9 to 6 or if we want to reduce
it for every three oranges so we're
going to divide this by three so for
every three oranges we are going to have
two apples we are going to have two
apples so notice this is just exactly
what we had up here but when we had
apples to oranges it was 6 to 9 6 apples
for every 9 oranges and now when it's
oranges to apples we say it's nine two
six nine oranges for every six apples or
we could say for every three oranges we
have exactly two apples